Police departments across the country
are now using artificial
intelligence technology
to evaluate officers in the field.
The program uses
AI to scan body camera footage
and then analyzes
whether or not
the police
and officer
handle the situation professionally
or not.
CNN's Vanessa
Cambridge saw firsthand
how this technology works.
Officer Dan Janita is on patrol.
He has all his tools for the day,
including his body worn camera
which automatically captures
videos of his encounters with civilians.
Safety first. Absolutely.
20 videos a day over 100 hours a week.
His final invisible piece of equipment,
artificial intelligence,
a program called Truglio,
which analyzes what he records.
Did you have fears
about what it meant
to have artificial intelligence
tracking your day to day?
I did have apprehensions.
It is high.
Technology can sometimes have drawbacks.
It's not perfect.
But at the same time,
I've seen things play out
enough where technology has helped us.
And that is what truly was co-founder
and CEO Anthony Tassone is aiming for
right now.
We started truly oh.
After George Floyd was murdered
in May of 20. 20.
How do we prevent this
from happening again?
What percentage of body
camera footage gets reviewed now?
A fraction of 1%.
And truly,
you could look at what percentage of body
cam video. 100%.
The A.I.
was trained by humans to detect
5 million key terms.
I got him in the yard
like profanity, noncompliance,
as well as professional language
or explanations.
The goal is detecting early,
problematic police behavior
before it turns deadly.
I get an email alert every day at 6:00.
Dan Schneider's chief
Ken Trouver of Castle
Shannon PD in Pennsylvania
has been using Trulia for a year.
He's also an advisor.
These are the key words that you put in.
They are.
So stop resisting custody arrest.
Anything to do with a pursuit.
I'm looking for high risk.
Things
truly transcribes
entire encounters
from body cameras,
but pinpoints
the exact moments that need revealed.
Stop resisting for us.
Just relax.
Not a
whole lot of resistance,
but it was giving me
exactly what I was looking for.
And so for you,
this is a good interaction
with one of your officers in a civilian.
It is.
The Alameda Police Department
in California has been using Trulia
for a little over a year.
It's seen a 36%
drop in use of force
by officers to Sony says the A.I.
pointed out risky interactions
with civilians
giving officers
the chance to review
and change their behaviors.
What would truly
those involvement
have been in a situation
like Tyreke Nicholls?
I feel very strongly that Trujillo
not only would have recognized,
obviously
the event of the murder of Terry Nichols,
but the hundreds of events
that took place prior to that.
I believe
Trujillo would have prevented
the death of Tyree
because it would have detected
the deterioration
in the officer's behavior. Years prior.
There are
18,000 police departments in the U.S.
just 20 are using Trujillo
with 20 more signing on this year,
including Aurora PD in Colorado.
It will be an early warning system
that will help save careers
and ultimately maybe even save lives
in 2019.
Three Aurora
police officers were charged
with the death of Elijah McClain
using excessive force during his arrest.
If we see just a little change
in the officers performance,
we'll be able to actually intervene
early on,
get them help, get them counseling,
get them training,
do whatever it takes
to get back on the right track.
Back in Cassel, Shannon Chief Trouver
says the technology has only proven
what he already suspected
about his officers.
What has this changed anything?
No, and I don't think that's a bad thing.
I want to catch something
before it happens.
I want to be reactionary.
We want to be looking ahead
to make sure
that we stay ahead of the game,
ahead of any issues.
And I don't think that's a bad thing.
Now, the
Seattle Police
Department was one of the first
to adopt Trujillo,
but in recent months,
they've actually canceled
their subscription
with the platform
because they had concerns over
citizen privacy.
We obviously asked Trujillo about this.
They said that
all of the data,
all of the video
lives on the department's servers.
So the department is the one in control.
And Trujillo also said
that there is a way
there are ways to protect privacy,
redacting certain information,
making sure citizens
feel like their footage
with encounters with police officers
are being looked at safely
and their information
is not going outside
of the police department.
You would need to know
the identity of a person
like he brought up
Terry Nichols, for example.
You need to know
the identity of the person
to get involved in a situation.
I so many questions.
This is so fascinating.
How expensive is it?
Can can departments afford this?
Departments can afford it.
If the municipalities and cities
are willing to pay for it,
it's about 20 to $50 per month
per officer.
If you're a larger department,
it is more expensive.
But there are federal
funding programs
that you can certainly apply
for it to help offset those costs.
But this technology being used
by a small group of police departments,
but obviously
the goal for
this founder
is to get it to go nationwide.
Yeah.
And it makes it made a good point
about it, too.
Yeah, of course, it'll prevent
lawsuit costs,
the costs to pay for
this could be at the end of the day,
maybe cheaper,
more affordable for some departments
who could face lawsuits in the future,
as you mentioned.
We'll see if it's adopted
on a widespread basis.
Vanessa, good report. Thank you.